i'm son kaufmann i'm in charge
of chrome mobile solutions at
google in france before we start
just to find out if we're really
among friends who of you have an
android phone in your pocket today great
almost everyone  everyone who who here has
already used the chrome browser
yeah everyone here for once and
who of you has already used a
chromebook a good majority it's
super good well ok so we're among friends
it's great so you  can you
wonder why in the context of an
event that is dedicated to the cloud
we talk to you about terminals it's a bit
and well because we think that the
cloud fundamentally changes the
way we work
before the terminal
it was a kind  bubble who had the
applications that contained the data
and who worked almost in
isolation from the rest of his
professional world today with the cloud
we really have the possibility of
accessing from a  n simple and
intelligent terminal to all the services
of the application solutions
offered by the cloud and therefore to access them
from anywhere anytime and
also for anyone and that is
precisely what  whoever who
is not necessarily there today if we
look at the statistics there are
about 3 billion employees in the
world and only about a
billion terminals between computers
and smartphones that are managed in
companies
it means that practically two-
thirds of the employees in your companies
do not have access to the value of the
value proposition of the cloud
today and at google we have
no intention of changing that and
ultimately you  allow you to
deploy and make terminals
available to as many people
as possible to support the
digital transformation in your
company to provide terminals
and access to the
information collaboration system for jobs  There are
much more of them, whether on the
assembly lines in the workshops
where the salespeople or even to
invent new ways of operating
new businesses for your company
directly with your
customers and for that you need
secure terminals manager and which
will not negatively impact the costs
and resources of your organization
haiti this is therefore the whole idea
of google's proposal in busin
ss around our two opera
ing systems that you
know android well on one side
for smartphones and tablets
and then on the other side the one I
thought you knew a little less
well but I'm glad to see that
many of you have had to try the
chromebook so chrome os  which is an
operating system that will
equip laptops with stops and integrated screens
so computers so we
present more android the most popular
operating system  s used in the
world which equips more than a billion
of smartphones and and I believe that the
second billion and is in sight so
it is today a blockbuster success
worldwide and the statistics tell us
that even more than two thirds
terminals deployed in companies
are terminals that run on
the android operating system
the story is a little different
for chrome os it is an
operating system that google friend made
available only a few
years ago but which knows  today a
very strong craze and very strong growth
so especially in the United States
since the market
finally the market that's a
commercial thing we will say that the dome the
world of education and is today
or has  chose chrome os in a
big way more than half of the
students and pupils in the united states
are equipped with a chromebook today
and it has created an equally
important consumer market with more than more than
50,000 c  hromebook that are being activated
every day 20% growth in this
consumer market in the united states is
also in the business and
that's what we're going to talk about today with
you see nearly a million
chromebooks that are  sold in
companies every year so I see
there I will start with chrome by
chrome companies it is since it
is my favorite field and
then my colleague nadia will then talk to you
about android in the company and
to start  I suggest you see
a short video so I apologize it
's happening in the united states it's a fact
an American financial institution
which has deployed chromos which wins role
of videos above on the left
this time
so here is what is  what's good
what's this this
ability to deploy chromebooks
in companies and to operate them as
we saw just now with charles
schwab
that's what  'we call like business
so what is it exactly  Like a
company, it starts with
debate and 6 terminals that were designed
specifically for chrome os, it's
not ehpads and PCs on which we had
installed the operating cem, they
were designed specifically for this
operating system.
and we even invented our own
vocabulary of chromebooks for
laptops chromebooks for central units
and chrome bays for its
all-in-one screens that
run chrome os so on these terminals we will
install chrome os including chrome os
c  what is it an
operating system that is provided by
google on its terminals and which will
update automatically
with updates that google provides
on all terminal parks
whether they are general public to  companies that
have been deployed in the wild and then
finally we come to offer a
chrome companies proposal which is done
through a license that will
allow access to a certain name  ber of
features and services that will
allow companies to
integrate chrome vikes into the company
and control them and
secure them to saints
within companies in a simple way that's
what  which is chrome companies
while its is its functionalities
and its services in the group under
four main families I would
say functionalities
the first is everything related
to productivity and there we will find
the three main families
of applications that will run on a
on a chromebook on a on a
chrome terminal the browser first of all
so there is a chrome browser on a
on a chrome os it's not by chance
that's why it's called  chrome os
you will be able with the
fully managed business features the configuration of this
browser to ensure that they are
ready to be used by your
employees to access your
web applications q  whether it is through the
extensions that you have been
able to deploy and secure all that by
restricting, for example, to certain
certain addresses where certain
second large family
applications are android applications and that is a
novelty for this year  is the
possibility of installing and running
on chrome terminals all the
applications that have been developed
for android and managing them via
google play, some of which you
certainly know well are brought
to android which will be
managed for once  by the company and I will
show you a little later finally
third major type of applications
are heavier applications which
thanks to virtualization tools
like like citrix like vmware
we allow you to access
workspaces at  remote
virtual workspaces on these
environments citrix vmware and others
this is what the solution will allow you to do
to access
applications and being productive second
large family of features is
everything related to the control of its
terminals once they have been
deployed in your organizations so
provided with the solution you have access
to an administration console in the
cloud  which will allow you to manage
more than 200 configuration policies for
the terminals themselves is in it to
restrict the uses or to
secure
the uses if you live in a world
before the internet
maybe you want to integrate these
terminals into the existing  like active
directory
that is also possible with rome
companies where the management for the cost
will be done as for the rest of your
terminals in an active tig directly
or a third option is
to integrate it with vmware backspace one
airwatch a  novelty that we also launched
last summer and which therefore
allows you to manage chrome terminals in
the same way as you manage your
mobile terminals or  lens or other
windows or mac terminals within
your organization
and then finally you will be able to
integrate with your printing systems
or manage shared use for
example of a chromebook or
a kiosk mode if you  if you reduce the
use of the terminal to a single
application
for example for general public use
or customers in a dance a store
for example
thirdly saas security and it is
important I think that we could
perhaps have put it first chrome
os was designed to be secure from its
conception
it is not something that was
added afterwards and therefore there are
elements as well at the level of the
hardware as the firmware as of the oes
itself to secure  chrome terminals
there is in each chrome terminal like
like the chromebook that I have here a
secure chip called a tpm which
will check them for the signature of the osce
which was provided by google and ensure
that it  there was no  of modifications this os
then there is no application which
comes to be installed on its
operating system since it is it is
chrome or well and is therefore
applications which run
in tabs in with a system  from sam
boxing which means that there is no
malware
startle chrome os is not thirty six
months old there is no paco ware and to
date there has been no compromise
and  compromises no it's not said
that security attack on a terminal
on a chrome terminal
we have I believe a million dollars to
take for the first person
who finds a
security breach
which means that  suddenly there is
no anti virus either and there is ultimately no need to
manage all these
security aspects finally in the proposal
that we are undertaking you will find
24/7 support from google  for
your entire fleet of terminals
and also the possibility of
administering access to your  rminals at a distance
here I propose that it is necessary that a
switch very words that they I propose
that very quickly to show
you to show you rods where he switch demo
then speak in English so navy to
show you simply
so for those who  wouldn't have seen
what a chromebook looks like
so it's ultimately an
operating system on which
the chrome browser will mainly run
and then so there the novelty is this
possibility of accessing google here please
go  tell me but there's not a lot
of application in your google please
why because this terminal here and
managed by the administration console and
we see here so thanks to my account is
managed by the in the domain to which
I belong and  so the android apps
available to me have been restricted by my
admins and so in the one
i can install i will choose one
at random
for example microsoft outlook don't know
why someone  would like to install
outlook but hey just to show you
that we can install an android application
that's it it's installed and I
can announce it here we go so you
see very simply how android
has been managed here on this on  what we
book
fecan switch pact i will end by
mentioning one to our customers what i
started with an american video you
will say it happens in the united states
no it happens in france also it is
a reference for  we who are you
will also find the article here
send you the photo / on our blog
fraikin one of the French leaders in the
management of company fleets
if your company has trucks and there is
a good chance that it is fraikin
who who  provide them to your
company and who manage them they have
deployed kronberg more than
almost a thousand chrome os
in all their branches distributed
throughout france has therefore been used by
staff in their workshop and  in
the eu in their agency to manage
everything I would say the entry and exit of
vehicles all the business finally
of an agency years why did
they choose the way of the chrome solution
first of all because it could
manage  since
the reporter since the year since
paris all the terminals deployed in
the branches without needing to have
the expertise of the staff on site so
that was ctcl and secondly it was
economically interesting
compared to  what they
previously used stations stations
to access their mainframe because
they are still on a
mainframe for their
main applications they still moved to the
cloud for this part there and therefore they
were able to access
these mainframe applications from  the
browser but while offering
their collaborators via the
browser access to the entire corporate collaboration system from
which his
collaborators were excluded  read before and
so it was an extremely important contribution in value
for them
in addition to continuing and having
fully managed access to their
information system to their business applications
so I invite you to go see
it on this I m  stop and i will
therefore pass the floor to my colleague nadia perez
to talk to you about android companies
thank you philippe hello to all or rather
good evening it's already late i hope i
'm not going to knock you out brossard last
these are actually i was talking to you
of andry in the company but before
we talk about it more at length I
think the best thing is to start with
this video kelly switch videos plus
taxes
[Music]
class
and this match at stephen hates a trial
mubarak
photo cm
[Music  ]
all but who would have made me chic
[Music]
cole
all hair
all edges who searched
invain with
all sails years
[Music]
the washington farmhouse
a greenhouse sculptor
nvidia quadro
terrible waxman has planted
[Music]
enjoy it was indeed a video in
English there were no subtitles
I hope you still only
follow with these images this video
it interesting because it shows
different uses of android in
the  company we know their use in
productivity 1
but there are also other uses and
how androïd contribute to
digital transformation said with
different uses
so yes that's I come back a little
on a figure that was
mentioned by a  philippe earlier this
is finally the
market share of android in business so in
2010 we were at 28% and in 2016 according
to the idc report
we are at 70 7% market share it  is
an important figure which is explained by
the many investments and
the commitment really the android team to
meet the needs of companies I
invite you to look at the report to
have a little more information but
it is a figure which for  is
important to us and  i finally correspond to
all its benefits for companies
to use our android platform this
is a few the first is
the existence of multi profile we have the
possibility on android to create a
professional profile which is
completely separate from profit
personal and isolated also the
benefits here is that on this
professional profile we will bring
additional management controls a
certain number of needs which meet
the administrators while accepting
all the ranks of a personal use on
this same device and in
finally respecting the
confidentiality needs of this personal use
we will see later I will
demonstrate the coexistence of the pro
personal on an android device in
business another reason
in any case another program another
benefit of the choice of android  it is the
choice of the form factor the variety of
various android whether on
technical specificities because it has
nfc what is this  that
the screen size the
battery capacity we are also not only going to
offer different formats
whether we are using smartphones or tablets
we are also going to offer rugged terminals
that's what we see in the
video we don't have  not just the smartphone, the
classic tablet, we also have
rugged terminals to meet
business needs,
so we will finally be able to find the
device that matters, which suits the
business needs of companies,
another major progress for us
is different deployment methods
that we offer to companies and not
only manual counting we put on our
gmail and then we will install the
leg there is even the mdm agent on the
phone we will propose other forms
of deployment because deployed a
fleet of 100 terminals c  is not the
same thing as deploying a fleet of ten
thousand terminals, we have to
offer solutions that are a little more automated, a
little simpler and more productive for
companies, so we  is going to have
solutions based on qr codes based on
nfc no device with a sindup pupil
which will provision different devices in
a row but also something
new that you may know a
little less which is called the 02 10
complaints  so zero touch is what that
means is that there is zero
user action I will show
you later that there is still a little I
will show you that later through the
presentation and then another benefit
this google likes  the group leaves and
the richest application star in
the mobile ecosystem
we have two million applications on
google today and this is one
of the reasons for strong
adoption with many concerns but it is also true in
b to b but it is all the more true in
b to b that we can have a foot store
the company we can have a private pelé store
the administrators of fat mobile
can set up a pelé store
restricted to employees l  company
we will find in this  plat store
applications from the public catalog
among the two million
plat applications typically will select
a salesforce a competitor to have
other parts v
and then we will also be able to offer
private company
applications to the applications you have developed
for you you will benefit
from all the power of the ppt the stores
today to publish
applications
the pelé store it has existed for
years it is a
robust platform which has a lot of richness in
terms of publishing applications
but we will also find other
benefits, in particular a little more
functionality and modularity in
the inability to offer applications
to employees, for example we will be able
to silently push an
application on the images of your
collaborators you force you can
force  the installation of certain
applications on the professional account does
not affect the accounts p  personal here we
respect the privacy of
end users important we can also
choose to put a white list
so users can choose from
their catalog of applications the one that
suits their use companies
there other benefits in particular it is in
security term
we can restrict the user to
install applications from
only dupes the blinds benefit
from security mechanisms dupes the
blinds which would come back later
but the tester is extremely secure
so restrict the source
of installation of the applications
only  of the story it's a way
to ensure the security of your
users
and if we talked a little bit about
security but when it's that it's a
theme on which we often come to
search and to which we answer we do
a lot of safety workshops,
whether with our partners or our
customers, we really want to answer
your requests, your questions, your questions.
uistudies and we realize that the
android security model is very
little known a security workshop in
general
at least it is one hour in
discovery mode it can last an hour it
can last half a day
if it is necessary that  we go into detail there
is a lot to say I'm going to
try
smell 7 7 hours of discovery in this
live not necessarily obvious I
invite you to come back a month if you
want to know more and I'm going to
summarize them by these four  security layers
the first is hardware because if
we can pass this relying on hardware
to secure to protect
the user therefore starts on a base that
is a bit wobbly so for us we
need to be sure that at the hardware level
we can rely on it
so how do we do to secure the
hardware when we only produce the pixel
it's a question we can
ask ourselves when I say we rely on a
duty I'm not talking only about the pixel
this  would be too restrictive and then it  is
not yet available in france but
it would be really very restrictive for
you no I speak
globally all the divine cgm is where
the divas sandridge ms if you want
to know a little more about gms in a
few words in bridge msc the
certification of  'android
google certification for android
I invite you to look a little more
on the internet if you want to go
further globally in europe
we are on gms images for
companies don't worry about that
but now if I come back to this on
the hardware layer  what do i
mean by that we make sure that our divas and
gms have in their chipset a
secure area called the tt-rs zone
in this area
we will store all the
critical elements of the user  it's going to be
these passwords it's going to be these
certificates knew of these
authentication elements they are stored in
this zone which has a crisis in mind and at
the hardware level someone who comes to
steal your devi  what and who eventually
will graze it or do whatever
he can't have access to this
euro zone well lean on it on this
hardware layer okay
above this hardware squash we will
also add security mechanisms
on the  platform on loes even
then obviously we have all the
possible controls since the and we who
supply the west what we want to do
at the bone level is to ensure
the integrity of the device and the data
normally of things to say  there it
would take at least 45 minutes for you
to get into the whole floor cite a
few examples
first example it may be the
verify boot so ensure the integrity of
the water this moment we turn on the device it
could also be the  within
app boxing an app ca
n't access another
app's data
unless they have requested
permission this
is also
real time permission permission management
so when i insta  lle an application
for the first time I have to accept
the permissions okay but often
the users accept all the
permissions he does not really look at
what it is and it is when he launches
the application that in fact it should be
that we ask the user for more
do you agree that I go and
dig into his contacts and that's
exactly what we
actually do we read what reads it we
say the permissions to the first one
installation me on the first attempt
first time we launch the application
is happy to access contacts or
something else we ask users again
and there from a contractual point of view he
understands what we are trying to give him
ask
and it is he who approves or not this
permission so an application can only
access the data of another
application if the
user authorizes it and in a context where he
understands what he authorizes there will be
plenty of  other things i could
d  go on on this layer there but
we have to move forward and I have moved on to
this third plus which is google play
protect this relatively recent and little
known and yet very efficient the
google foot protect in a few words
it is the  anti malware produced by google
for android users on which
is available on everything he says vincent
droid up to jelly bean since in fact
you just have to open the clae store
to access it you quote android
g8 actors we had a  a certain number
you should all have it already
available on your device I will
show you later when we do
the demonstration so typically what
it does is that it had checked
on installation when trying
to install d  an application if it
is not dangerous
we will come to Cannes and analyze it and
inform the user
of the result it would be good if it
does not go well
we will look at it later and then
the other  security layer
actually if the api d  e management is what
we actually call android
companies so these three
layers are peeled off protect platform and
hardware that's true for all
android users even outside the context of
companies that's really for
everyone and  then we add additional layers
of control for
companies
typically we will for example prevent
the installation of unknown applications tonight
we will prevent the copy paste from the
professional profile to the personal profile
a certain number of things we will
restrict we will  prohibit a certain
number of things on the professional profile
I would like to come back a little more
on the google pays protect because
it is something important
the taste of the protect club in fact it will be
based on two things which are that
i would like to mention here relying
on something called the
verify ap which is sure the device
is what allows us to scan
applications even in m  ode offline verify
has crashed on the device and it will start
on installation
my first installation of an
application but it will also
rely on google cloud on
services on cloud technology and in
particular on machine learning
c  are extremely
powerful algorithms that can anticipate
new trends and
potentially new threats that could
affect our users so we
rely on the best that google
offers to protect our
android senators so in terms of numbers
that  does that mean does that mean
50 billion applications have been scanned
per day 2 billion we already have the 2
billion divas gms and dubai divas
who are certified there are all the others
in addition but that those are the
devices
there are protected devices on the planet
in the world and for applications that
have not passed the first
security scan and we need to
look so  re more rigorous
it represents 500 thousand applications per
day that we will come to dissect and
ensure that there is no danger for
our users
yeah it is extremely secure and
user experience it looks
like that there we are  sure
that the application stores that the public or corporate stores it
doesn't matter we will be able to
go to this tab and check that
google pays protect to scan all
of your applications can
manually launch the scan the scan it will
launch regularly even after
the installation of the applications
it will launch regularly on the
basis of algorithms that we have put in place
then checks that everything is going well and
then tells you that everything is going well if
we detect something that is not
clear  we notify the user be careful
it doesn't work but we leave you the choice
what you want to force the installation
anyway it's
the user's choice
that's the first option if it
doesn't go well there is a  another  re option
is that we are sure that it will not
go well we are sure that it is an
application which is dangerous in this
case ans warns the user that we are
not installing the application and we
withdraw it
there we force our hand because we know that
it is not good what what we want is
above all to give more visibility and
control to the user
whether we are in business or in his life
big  public we want to give
visibility and control on the other hand
for companies so I spoke about
that earlier the management APIs
will say that there are 3 types there really
device management
so that controls at the level  of the
device prohibit the factory reset to tell you
this is the type of use of
bluetooth other things application management
so there it is really using the
corporate playsport to offer
applications for your users for
your employees and the methods of
deployment  of which gct I mentioned
a few earlier we have  one
that I would like for which I
would like more particularly by the
zero touch seals
I told you zero talent arose
by action but we still have a
few the clusive it goes very quickly
I'll tell you what happens and
then  then I let you watch
we can do it the other way we can
watch then and then follow
while explaining to you what it is
overall what is happening is that we
receive a brand new phone that is very
beautiful as a  'user we launch the
wizard and the wizard asks us to
connect to the internet either through
wifi or through the summit, it
doesn't matter, you just have to be connected
to the internet at the first
internet connection the phone is able to
detect that it belongs to it  has been
identified as belonging to a
company at this time it will be
able to recover the rim control
which is selected by the company so
there in this case it is a
demonstration application that o  n calls test des
pc it could be the byron leg it
to be the device policy agent of
google mdm it could be airwatch
to be other control agents
which automatically goes down to the
vice which will install itself on
device and  then just follow the
wizard we know from to insert your
business account on this control agent this
is what we see here here
it checks who owns this device
the company that pushed the speed of the pc
the drop test  falls back on the
device and then just has to add its
business account on this
control agent in the event that the device has
been routed
before we connect to the internet first
in fact what happens because the first
connection we go when  even detect
that it belongs to a company
we will start by doing a factory and
seven out of ten vice before installing the
accor control leg starts again on
something clean to be able to
do the rotation of the divine 10 and then
I  I will now move on to my
demonstration of the professional profile
Cannes the switches of drunkenness please
good so here is the distance that I am going
to propose to you it is the coexistence pro
personal
but we could only have pro 1 if
we wanted we could  look and say to
yourself go for it only pro say that
pro applications a pro account
pro data it would be possible but here
I would like the personal pro so on this
own hoop see that I called store
to the public I have my chrome  normal I have
my idea but gimont google+ that's
the world it's my personal use
can you also say it's sometimes we
find there the plestan and with the
badge icon is the icon here so that's  this is my
corporate plestan this is my
domain the company
then I have a whole whole folder there a whole
folder with all my applications
that my company pushed me I was offered
that I voluntarily  install if i
wanted to install other
apps
i will surely plestan  business I go
back to my
professional applications home of the beaver and there
these are the applications that my
administrators whitelisted
me I chose put back the application and for
example I want to install ali I
want to play a little  with what sports
my professional use today
I could be part of the
virtual reality team of a company and we
offer cardboard for for to
work and the malice of scattering
protect good it's the google application
but  any application would
pass the scan again is there it
has been validated
we can install it one important thing
that I did not say that the protect does
not only apply to
applications from google stone key
protect applies  to all the
applications that we try to install
on the device even if they come from an
email even if it comes from a file that
has been installed on google drive or other or
from a website that is not recognized by
google we will scan everything  in beijing
trying to settle on waltzes the
beaches to open it
if i wanted to check how google
pied protect worked well or if i
wanted to force a manual scan yes the
last time i forced the
manual stopover it  is today at 5:09 p.m.
I checked before going on stage
and there I'm going to restart it he's gone
for a ride